but would you please join us for a  moment as many of you know there is a  scene in the Martian where much  character astronaut Mark Watney the size  that Mars counts as international waters  and therefore he must count as a space  pirate look back in a few minutes the  promise and I will give all these  diplomas but right now Aneesh and I  would like to present to you a very  special MIT certificate usually usually  you can only receive the certificate  from MIT s Department of Athletics  physical education and Recreation and  only if you meet all their standards in  archery sailing fencing and pistol but  is you with Mark Watney have done so  much to promote swashbuckling  appreciation for science engineering and  space exploration we are honored to  present to you a special an authentic  MIT pirate certificate